now we're going to turn to a program
putting at-risk young people on a path
to work and a path to stability at some
point every year about three and a half
million young adults in this country
that's ages 18 to 25 are homeless that's
more than the entire population of
chicago or houston think about that we
found a business that is stepping up to
help by only hiring young people who are
at who are homeless or at risk of
becoming homeless christina raffini now
shows us how it is giving them a clean
start to a promising future in our
series a more perfect union
connor copley's job
sucks
and buffs i like it it's a good job and
at times shines why does your side look
better than my fries probably because
i've been working here for three months
here at detail works near burlington
vermont employees work from the inside
out both on the cars and themselves
growing up did you think that you would
end up being in a shelter at some point
no i had much higher hopes than that
for the past two years copley has lived
at this shelter run by spectrum youth
and family services
the organization helps at-risk young
people like him find jobs
trouble was
only 40 percent were able to keep them
they don't know how to show up at work
on time they don't know how to work as
part of a team they don't know how to
dress for work you need somebody who
wasn't going to assume that these kids
were coming in with the knowledge of how
to hold down a job that's right so
executive director mark redmond decided
to launch an in-house business to teach
participants some of the life skills
they might have missed along the way we
had 26 different ideas what were some of
the ideas burlington's 50th coffee shop
which we don't really need burlington's
15th thrift store which we don't really
need and somebody mentioned car
detailing three years later detail works
led by two former corrections officers
is really working there are so many jobs
you're like did i really accomplish
something today i hear you know you
accomplished something the hands-on
approach appeals to josh moran who says
he struggles with anxiety and depression
basically you wax on and wax you really
actually yeah you really wax on there a
year here landed him a higher paying job
at fedex but and i did not like it it
was just too robotic for me and i have a
lot of adhd so like
just sitting in one spot you know taking
out the pack just putting them in their
cages was just
so we came back they called and they're
like yeah we really want you back 86
percent of the program's participants
stay here at least 90 days already
and many go on to other jobs before
detail works and even at detail works
i woke up had a cough call out you know
didn't have a way into work call out now
charles hemingway makes it happen
walking more than a mile each way to the
job he's had for four years detail works
has
taught me everything i know about my
work ethic about communication about
making sure that i take care of myself
as well as take care of my job so that
you know i never wind up in a situation
where i'm jobless or homeless again he
recently donated 250 back to the program
to help others
like connor copley i built up a lot of
good work ethic and
i'm getting my stuff in order does that
make you feel good about yourself very
gives me hope the rest as they say
is in the detail
for cbs mornings i'm christina rafini in
williston vermont
boy thank you guys for the job you do
when i had a car you feel good driving
around a car nice piece christina very
well done